it's funny because to me monogamy as is
it's not a it doesn't make sense for it
to be a default like to me monogamy goes
against human nature
that's in some sense like romance is a
[__] you to the way the world works
really yeah like it's a like Romeo and
Juliet romance like
traditional description of what romance
looks like versus like sure there's like
a million variations of that but in in
my in my head like this partnership
that's for a long time together is a
kind of you know like uh I don't know
like True Romance you know that movie
it's a really [__] good movie okay
this is just like a
you're together
against the world
yeah that's the
I mean that's what close friendship
feels like it's like ride or die yeah
like that I guess it doesn't it it
doesn't it can be it could span across
multiple you can have multiple partners
in that way yeah absolutely but I just
don't see monogamy as like this
definitely not a default yeah I would
actually like honestly would probably
see polyamory as a more natural default
yeah I mean I guess it depends what you
mean by default like most of human
history has been sort of a weird mix
like you get polygamy and monogamy or
the kind of the main sure but I think
it's just like human nature like yeah
people are attracted to other people and
they want to yeah especially in longer
term relationships I I tracked and my
relationship survey I checked the amount
of cheating over time in a relationship
like how long have you been in this
relationship and how have you cheated
what's what's the results of that men
cheat a lot a lot uh women too but
mentioned about 30 more than women do I
also asked men and women to predict if
they think their partner has cheated and
people's predictions were about the same
so people roughly predicted that they're
male or female like spouse uh hadn't she
about the same rate but mentioned much
more than women so who uh who was more
correct in their prediction though uh so
men were more correct in their
prediction predicting women and women
were that moon are more off women
thought men cheated much less than they
actually did
and but both of them were off but like
the male Gap was significantly more so
yeah I mean you're right when you say
monogamy is not default like I think
you're like really getting at something
like human beings are just especially in
long-term relationships difficult to
only want one person but to be fair I
think manami and commitment are very
different I think you'd be incredibly
I've known so many very long-term super
committed poly couples that live lives
that look very similar to the very
romantic monogamous couples like
children houses like 20 years yeah and
that that works great for them